today's guitar tip is brought to you by
arpeggiato my online music school
specializing in all things echo block
you can sign up for online lessons with
one of our expert teachers in
instruments like
classical guitar fingerstyle guitar ood
loot and many more
so head over to arpeggiator.com to learn
more and don't forget to grab a ticket
to one of our online monthly events
hey friends eight years ago
i released this song chino pity number
one by eric city
which was originally written for piano
and i recorded it for my youtube channel
and a lot of you have asked me in those
eight years
basically how do you do these really
cool bell-like
sounds well they're called artificial
harmonics
and i thought today i could teach you
how to do it
[Music]
and the good news is whether you play a
nylon string guitar or steel string
acoustic electric if you play with nails
or without nails
you can still play artificial harmonics
so if you have a guitar
go ahead and grab it and get ready to
learn this really cool
technique
all right if we're going to get good at
this technique of playing artificial
harmonics
we first must make sure we're really
good at natural harmonics
[Music]
so what is a harmonic well it gets
pretty scientific pretty quick
but to simplify every note consists of
a fundamental pitch
and that's the pitch that we're
perceiving bum
it's the note you would say oh that
sounds like an e however
it's not just an e that pitch is
actually made up of an
overtone series which is a series from
that note we're hearing the fundamental
there exists a series of frequencies
above that pitch
and the amalgam of those frequencies
make up
that note so believe it or not within
this sound you're actually hearing
[Music]
and more notes that are actually too
high for us to even perceive
in fact how loud or soft those overtones
are in their intensity
is actually what controls the timbre
and so a harmonic is just when we
isolate one of these pre-existing
overtones so for example if i play this
e
and i want to point out one of those
overtones isolate it
[Music]
that is a harmonic that bell-like effect
and harmonics are produced on
all string instruments at specific
places
at different ratios along the stream
length so exactly halfway between the
bridge
and the nut uh is the 12th fret
and that's called a node it's a place
where the string vibrates
less apparently and so if you just touch
there lightly that's how we produce the
harmonic if you find a different ratio
you get a different harmonic different
ratio different ratio
of the division of the string
[Music]
okay so let's get you doing this if you
don't know already this is pretty simple
and actually i think it's pretty
instantly gratifying which is good news
take your ring finger on your fretting
hand for me that's my left hand
we're going to go to the 12th fret of
the first string the high e string
and we're going to use our ring finger
to basically
touch so lightly like a weight of a fly
on top of the string and we're actually
going to position our finger
directly above the metal normally when
we pluck
a note we want to put our finger inside
of the fret usually to the left
just to the left of the metal never on
top because it buzzes
or kind of produces a muted sound
however in harmonics you
want that position so we position our
finger just above the front
without any pressure and we pluck
normally in the right hand
that's a harmonic
now if your harmonic didn't sound like
mine here are some quick
tips that you can work on to practice
this over the next week or so
in your right hand or your plucking hand
if you pluck by the bridge
that helps bring out a clearer harmonic
as opposed to
sounds more bell-like by the bridge if
you have nails
definitely use nail um if you don't have
nails
and you're plucking pluck your hand
perpendicularly to the strings
right so not an oblique angle but more
perpendicular like this
that'll give you a very clear sound also
in your left hand
once you hear the sound of the harmonic
make sure you take
off your finger if you leave it down
[Music]
the note gets muted did you hear it got
muffled
but now watch what happens if i take my
finger off
the note sustains and the last tip i'll
give you now for harmonics
is a pretty cool one um if you look at
your fingerprint
on your finger there's kind of a swirl
natural swirl that leads to
the middle of the finger kind of on the
flat of the finger so
normally we play on the tip of the
finger kind of the fleshy
pad of the finger but actually we're
going to find that spot the center of
your fingerprint
swirl and actually if you look closely
your finger
like actually has this protruding bit of
flesh
right there and for me that is the
perfect
harmonic point so if we touch that ever
so
slightly to the string it produces
a perfect harmonic because there's so
little skin on the string it's just
touching the node
that we talked about earlier and nothing
around it
okay and now that you can play a good
12th fret harmonic
on the first string this actually works
on all the strings
on the 12th fret
it works because it's the halfway point
of each string
and this will work actually as well on a
banjo cello
loot theorbo you name it it's just the
natural function
of a string you can also produce
harmonics on the seventh fret
and the fifth fret
there are more places like the fourth
fret
which is actually the same as the ninth
fret
and you can of course go even further
than that but remember those are the
overtones that get so high that we can't
really hear them well you can kind of
hear them on the
sixth string
and then they're kind of gone
so here's my suggestion if you're new to
harmonics
or even if you've done it before i like
to push you a little farther
uh stick with the 12th fret seventh
and fifth you have lots of different
strings and notes there you could play
and i want you to try and improvise or
even compose a song
using those notes just pluck
miscellaneous strings and see if you can
come up with something
catchy
[Music]
it's pretty easy to kind of everything
you do sounds kind of cool
in fact i even remember from high school
i even
composed a little melody once using
these harmonics
[Music]
so have fun at this point and get really
good at making
strong clear bell-like harmonics
okay we're about to go to the next level
if you need more time
if you feel like that's pretty new for
you don't hesitate to spend a week and
just get really good
at those harmonics but if you're ready
to move on
let's go uh the next level would be to
play those same natural harmonics
but all in the right hand so the way we
do that
is we're going to go to the same note we
found before
first string 12th fret but this time
instead of using our left hand we're
actually going to
touch the 12th fret on that same point
the little swirl
of your fingerprint very very lightly
so it's the index finger of your
plucking hand actually for me it's my
right hand
so this now leaves the rest of your hand
free and there's two ways to pluck the
string from here
we can either do what a lot of steel
string and finger style guitars do which
is
you can kind of bring your elbow down
and then you use your thumb
my thumb's back here and it's actually
going to be the one that that plucks
the string so with my index finger
extended
touching the harmonic but not pushing my
thumb will
pluck the string and so you can play all
the things i played earlier
[Music]
with that effect and that does work the
other way is you touch the
node the harmonic but instead of
bringing your thumb down you use your
ring finger
[Music]
i like this a lot more and the main
reason is because
i don't have to kind of change my whole
hand position but maybe even more
importantly
this frees up my thumb and other fingers
to actually still pluck
so when i pluck a harmonic
i can pluck other notes and then play
harmony so choose
which one feels good to you and either
way
i would again point out this would be a
good point to spend a little bit of time
and just get
really used to this
in terms of accuracy and clearness in
each
bell-like harmonic
[Music]
okay let's move on to the last step
which is artificial harmonics
but before i get there i just want to
say if you're enjoying my guitar tips
and want to see more i actually have a
bunch of
patron-only guitar tips already uploaded
to my patreon
and so if you want to support this
channel that would be very kind of you
and also you would get access to
all of those extra guitar tips instantly
as well as
all this behind the scenes content and
more so check that out
if you're interested but let's get back
to the artificial harmonics our last
step of the day
if you feel uncomfortable at all with
the right hand alone harmonics make sure
you spend some extra time there because
what we're going to do now is we're
going to add an extra layer sort of like
you know rubbing your stomach and
patting your head at the same time
so we have to be really secure in the
right hand
because now we're going to bring the
left hand back in to do something
something else if you remember the
natural occurring harmonics only
happen at nodes at certain places like
the 12th
7th 5th and other places but you can't
produce any pitch
you want by adding the left hand in what
we're going to do is we're going to
basically turn the entire fretboard
into accessible harmonics
so that we can play virtually any notes
and this is a pretty cool thing because
this means we can play melodies and
scales and improvise sort of in any
direction rather than relying on
whatever happens to be naturally
occurring on the string
okay so let's learn it if you remember
the 12th fret harmonic
produces a note which is an octave
higher than the open string
and that's because it's exactly half the
length
of the open string right the twelfth
fret is just halfway at the halfway
point
now here's the cool thing what happens
if i
hold down the first fret on the first
string
now actually for all intensive purposes
my string isn't from here to here
it says from here to the first fret so
i've shortened the string
and i've moved the halfway point to the
13th fret so that means if i hold down
the
f on the first fret of the first string
and now
if i want to play a harmonic in the
right hand i have to play the 13th fret
but it works i can go back to the 12th
fret if i let go of the left hand
if i put back the left hand i have to
play the 13th
if i move this up to the second fret
it's always 12 frets higher 12 frets
is an octave that means i play the 14th
if i move it up again that's the 15th
so let's take a little melody how about
e
f g f e in tab it's
0 1 3 1 0 in harmonics it'd be 12
13 15 13 12.
so here we go ready go
it's a pretty cool effect now this is
the really cool moment because
we can keep going with this to play
basically whatever we want now
but in harmonics i can play full scales
if i want
basically whatever my left hand does my
right hand has to mirror it
an octave higher so let's have a little
fun how about
let's do the melody to the force theme
from star wars
[Music]
and now i'll do the exact same thing but
in harmonics
[Music]
and in fact this is where that idea i
mentioned before comes in handy if we
use our ring finger to pluck
we leave our thumb free to play open
strings in fact
in this case we can play an open e at
various points which adds
a thicker sound
[Music]
and then an a at the end to change the
harmony
and to me at least this is super cool
because what we've done is we've kind of
taken the normal
plucking sounds of a guitar and we've
expanded
its possibilities to include timbres and
sounds which aren't normally associated
with the guitar and that just makes it a
fuller more developed
instrument another great effect we can
do here now that we've learned how to
play artificial harmonics
is to play arpeggios so an arpeggio
means a
broken chord this is a chord
and to stagger those notes
is to break the chord and that's what an
arpeggio means
and we in fact do arpeggios now in
harmonics
which is actually easier than it sounds
because all we have to do
is play the chords in our left hand that
we already know and then
find the notes to pluck out in the right
hand let's take some easy chords let's
start with e minor
and then going to a minor okay so
let's hold down an e minor chord in our
fretting hand my left hand
and this is pretty cool because actually
if you remember
most the strings are open except for the
fourth
and the fifth which i played on the
second fret which means
any of those strings i can just play the
12th fret are normal
octave harmonic and then just for those
two strings i have to go to the 14th
and then i get to go back to the 12th so
i can arpeggiate that chord however i
want now
[Music]
and then here's the cool part i can
switch to a minor in my left hand
leave it there and now play the
corresponding harmonics again
on the first string that's 12 second
string is 13
and then 14 14 12
12.
[Music]
and now we can have some fun i can just
switch back and forth to create
new sounds
so please start grabbing some chords and
improvising
using these techniques you can improvise
and compose endlessly here
in fact i was just fooling around
recording here and i found some really
cool chords
that sound really beautiful and
artificial harmonics that i hadn't
played before
borrowing an a minor chord and then d
minor
i think this sounds particularly
harp-like
for me the highest level of artificial
harmonic playing comes when you play
completely separate lines
while playing artificial harmonics you
can play accompaniment
and a melody in harmonics just like we
do
[Music]
in that gymnopidi number one by
ericksontv we start with today
so i'm going to show you how to play a
bit of a simplified version for now
[Music]
and then again harmonics are just the
exact same notes in the melody
this part
[Music]
but 12 frets higher and now we get this
[Music]
and with those thumb base notes
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
there are more notes involved there and
we can actually with the other fingers
that aren't being used find more strings
to pluck
but then we get quite advanced i would
encourage you to find an arrangement of
this
and give that a go if you're interested
but at least for now we got you playing
artificial harmonics and the main thing
i wanted to do today is
show you this wonderful world of new
sounds you can make on the guitar and i
really hope you
learn to improvise and compose using
this explore these sounds they're so
magical
and ripe for music making so i hope you
enjoyed this
thanks again for watching and please do
check out my patreon if you're
interested in
more guitar tips and behind the scenes
content
see you next time
[Music]
you